[Music]
[Applause]
did that for example NCIS I was watching
NCIS yeah pretty popular show and then I
hit the info button and it said team of
crack detectives seek to find viewers
under 60 yeah so that gives you the idea
of what's going on here with this bit
yeah The Good Wife I was watching The
Good Wife yeah and then I hit the info
button
what scream queens is to your gay son
The Good Wife is to your unsatisfied way
my wife loves that show what does that
say Empire I was watching Empire that is
a kick-ass show
yeah and then I hit the button and it
said the show leopard cubs watch to find
out what happened to their missing
mother dr. Phil it's watching dr. Phil
then I hit the button critical life
advice from someone less qualified then
dr. pepper
he's gonna call me that Sapphira :
mr. blow his stash oh so Hell's Kitchen
I was watching the program Hell's
Kitchen yep
then I hit the info button just the
right mix of delicious food and domestic
violence hassle I was watching the show
castle I hit the button and it said no
now you're thinking about this kind of
fun do you mind if I try one you want
try one go ahead yeah everyone okay
let's tune into a celebrity food fight
on the Food Network there it is
let's hit the info button the greatest
show ever
premieres tomorrow night at 10 on the
Food Network
[Applause]
that was very funny but it's very
informative yeah
I've mentioned it okay Golf Channel I'm
watching the Golf Channel yeah then I
hit the info button and it says calming
down prison populations for over ten
years
it's very calming it is the Americans I
was watching the Americans hit the info
button what's the terrible wigs that
brought down the Berlin Wall I was
watching the player yep then I hit the
button two more seasons and Wesley
Snipes and the IRS are even and finally
diners drive-ins and dives
yeah that's the show then I hit the
button what Isis is too small Christian
villages this guy is to unlock burger
joint
[Applause]
no our job here is done
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]